you're best known obviously for the
portrait of the president when the
president asks you for a portrait you
say yes that's the first thing you do
and then how do you feel well then you
feel incredibly grateful and intimidated
when you sit down with Barack Obama and
decide and discuss how a painting is
going to take form here you're dealing
literally with the most powerful man in
the world you know so much of my work
before was about symbols of power the
performance of power the illusion of
them regalia surrounding power here's a
man who actually has power that's right
so who's the man yeah and I think that's
what that painting is about that's why
the collar loosens he leans forward to
you in in the painting space and the
source of that power is his connection
to the people yeah and so what I'm
really doing is painting power in its
most raw form did you have to negotiate
that sure especially this portrait
commissioned of this import you know is
going to be a negotiation a type of
conversation back and forth mm-hmm it's
also a conversation with myself how's
that go had that conversation almost
every day it's true and to make matters
worse I knew that it was such a historic
moment that I put a camera behind me to
record every moment of painting the
portrait the nature of time-lapse is
that you hear a little click every few
seconds and they're just like this tap
on the shoulder just in case you forgot
this is important nerve-racking yeah
well so how do you talk yourself through
that you know basically nothing gets you
through painting like painting you know
the subject obviously wants you because
they like your work but the subject also
has an idea of what they should look
like yes sure everyone knows how they
want to be depicted but I think this
type of portraiture is different because
it's not really about what he looks like
but rather what he feels like at least
and that's that's in my estimation yeah
I did a lot of research around
presidential portraiture heretofore and
there is a lot of protocol I wanted to
break that mold I did I definitely knew
that I wanted to create something
outside of the box I think you said in
one interview that Michelle Obama
initially had some reservations is that
right well you have to realize these
paintings have iterations yes now she
didn't have reservations with an actual
painting it was just an idea it was a
bad idea not all my ideas are the best
but I think it's great that we were able
to sort of triangulate the conversation
yeah we ate something that in the end
celebrates this man on a level that is
occupying all that pomp and circumstance
that we expect of a presidential
portrait but that feels very alive and
and now that feels like a modern
president as much of a spotlight as you
knew you'd be under for for that
painting was it more imposing in the end
than you thought or I knew that it was
going to be a lot but I didn't know was
gonna be that much it was more than you
thought the internet blew up yeah it was
the only thing I saw on Instagram it was
the only thing I saw trending up I mean
it was trending every major social media
platform how did you feel about that
response I felt incredibly embarrassed
that I didn't thank my mom on the speech
that I gave for the reveal I felt
incredibly honored and humbled I felt
nervous
that the world may not love this
painting as much as I do
mm-hmm but it's also a powerful feeling
to be the first African American artist
painting the first african-american
president